d'arcandor sur les réseaux sociaux ce
qui me manque cyril tandis qu'alain
chabat là on s'est croisé avec alain
chabat
on s'est parlé faut savoir qui a la
charge de connaît depuis assez longtemps
puisque j'étais son son stagiaire a
commise il a toujours été très très
sympathiques avec moi quand j'étais
stagiaire même serré je voyais tout le
temps et rigoler nous on s'était il y
avait une ambiance de ouf
et c'est vrai que j'étais très très fan
de lui après c'est vrai que voilà il ya
eu des petites sorties de part et
d'autre voilà et c'est vrai que c'était
monté en épingle par les journalistes on
s'est croisé avec alain on s'est parlé
et c'est vrai que voilà on s'est dit
tous les deux qu'on s'aimait beaucoup et
franchement voilà ça m'a fait ça m'a
fait beaucoup de bien de le voir parce
que c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un que
j'aime énormément vraiment qui m'a
toujours fait rigoler ce n'est pas pour
10 mathieu est vraiment que je que
j'adore tu le sedum et c'est vrai que ça
me paie ni qu'on soit fâchés alain et
moi je t'en ai même parlé plein de fois
mais je pense que ça va mieux et j'ai eu
un message de lui il est en montage de
burger quiz au mixage de burger quiz il
est en rade aussi et on vient on
essaiera de venir tous les troisièmes
prochaine je sais alors je sais que
voilà donc voilà donc ça va mieux après
jean qui renonce et je ne suis pas mon
téléphone mais c'est un dessin jour du
message merci très gentils messages pour
me voilà pour me dire d'hommes
je t'embrasse on peut pas être avec toi
parce que chantal et vous ne sont pas là
mais voilà on sera bientôt tous les
3èmes va très bien il vient à l'achat
manière à nous voir bientôt avec alain
oui donc oui c'est quoi c'est une
lourdeur cette fois dominé alors mais
moi j'ai oublié ce qu'on m'a dit de
faire alors question en principe je
devais dire des vannes c'est quoi le
bail c'est quoi c'est un cadeau kaeslin
a fait livrer pour vous ah super c'est
du chocolat
mélissa merci à tous les malades y
entrent
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
je retourne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans ses yeux